all right robbie yeah robbie uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally i'm originally from
bankrupt west virginia
i grew up in nitro and polka area
and uh
right now i'm in an apartment
by myself
um
three three jets during three three in
march
and you grew up out here in west
virginia what uh what was your family
life like
it was good um
i was actually adopted i never knew my
uh
biological
donors is what i call them
just uh
not sure code anything
i never knew my
why
mom because she was murdered and was an
alcoholic
that's what's wrong with me
when you say wrong with you what do you
mean wrong with you
well i'm glad
i said a syndrome called fetal alcohol
syndrome oh fetal alcohol syndrome yeah
from where my uh
fire diner drank and dead drugs when i
was in the womb
did a lot of damage to me
i've had to have a lot of life-saving
surgeries
including
air on my neck and
on my stomach
just to save my life
so it affects your health in terms of
like your breathing
yes it does you're very much better what
other kind of things
did it affect or does it affect
well it
affects my decision-making
effects
like everyday life
i struggle to
comprehend some stuff my parents have to
help me along with everything
but i am independent
it's just for like medical stuff
and money-wise
but other than that i'm pretty
independent you you finished school high
school
yes
i was out back in your hospital
which
is not a big deal
i mean
[Music]
that's life sometimes
and how was your childhood with your
adopted parents
it was great i would always go to like
cincinnati for my surgeries and stuff to
save my life
um i would always go to like
reds games stuff like that
just keep my mind off of
everything that was happening
in the hospital when i had surgeries
so the kids around me didn't make it
because of
different illnesses and stuff like that
still got traumatized by it yeah i'm
sure
and uh
you know it's
it's difficult sometimes just
remembering some of the stuff that had
happened
for example what do you mean
like
that dead next to me and the next year
and i ended up passing away
i remember i would hear screams in the
night sometimes
you know
just a bunch of
hospital stuff like
there were so many kids that died
in that unit
i was one of the lucky ones
and i'm blessed to have the surgeries
that saved my life
about like
four or five different
surgeries on my throat to expand my hair
away
so i wanted to on my stomach
because i was throwing up every day when
i was a child
did it make it difficult for you as a
child like in high school kids can be
cruel oh yeah i was bullied a lot
i mean there was sometimes that i wanted
to give up but i didn't
because i know
god has a better plan for me
than what this earth can offer
it's nice that you had good adopted
parents
yeah
somebody somebody took care of you
like your own parents your biological
parents were not able to
no well the only thing i know about
bible high school parents is my
my logical mother was murdered in
citizensville was somewhere
this was how old were you when this
happened you think oh gosh
maybe
a year older though
what do you know your dad at all no he's
it's a mystery
there was a few people that they thought
but
it might be
but they have no idea who it was
and your mom grew up where
i'm writing about the boy
you're your biological mom lived where
um i don't know anything about her
at all yeah but you've lived here in
west virginia near charleston yes for
your whole life yes
and as an adult have you had jobs or
anything like that i've had a couple of
jobs here and there
my first job was
i was a gopher first
company called
cccr
but just kidding and got the carpentry
they ended up
splitting and going out of business
and then i worked at walmart and it
didn't go too well because
of some
problems from my fatal alcohol syndrome
and then you know where this car washing
is now the five star
that used to be some
a uh barbecue place that i used to work
at
i would do the dishes and
less tables
and
then they ended up
selling out and not having enough
business so they got rid of me
so
[Music]
that's all my jobs i've had
and i hope everybody in my with this
photography
so the restricted airway is one
result from the fetal alcohol syndrome
yes i also have scoliosis bad scoliosis
yeah
and then your stomach you have issues
there too
yeah i think it was going like a soft
reflux or something like that
and that's part of the reason i had to
have the surgeries is to repair my
throat
from where i would puke every day
[Music]
so your voice has been affected like
this since you were young yes and
actually i paralyzed vocal cords
the way i'm talking right now is
i had to use a muscle in the back of my
throat
with air
i think it's the larynx or something
like that
but i'd have to get a doctor in here to
you know
name what it is
are there any other
effects from that like mental or
anything like that
yeah i've got
ahd really bad and
i'm very slow
coordinating stuff and i don't drive
because of that
[Music]
it would be so nice to be able to have
reliable transportation to places
my family does help but
i just don't like extra stuff that i
want to do
and is it difficult for you emotionally
to deal with this as an adult yes it is
you get depressed or
a lot actually yeah i'm sure yeah
it just makes me feel like
i mean there are good days mostly but
on my bad days some days i feel
worthless
but there's more good days than bad
that's great yeah
is it difficult to have relationships oh
yeah i'm sure right
i've
had abusive relationships in the past
i've let people in that's taken
advantage of me
money-wise and everything else
i even let someone
i thought was my friend
you know
hang out with me and everything and
that didn't go too well
ended up having to
cause someone to get her
out law enforcement basically
[Music]
do you have friends
do you have friends
yeah travis um
i have several of them yeah that's great
you don't need a lot just a few is is
enough right
you don't need a lot just a few is
enough right yeah
yeah definitely
do you feel any anger towards your mom
or your dad
i've forgiven her it's just the fact
that
i'm like this if she were still alive
i would ask her why did you do this to
me you know
it's
been really hard on me emotionally like
i said
yeah i mean
do you ever
try to put yourself in your mom's shoes
and understand that
she was going through her own battles
and yeah she couldn't just stop
stop drinking because it was the right
thing to do it's not as simple as that
sometimes i know that means
as an adult now
just saying
what if people addicted to things
including
some family members
that used to have addictions
you know it's
it's a difficult road
it changes you for sure
have you ever battled with that no i
haven't
just my depression yeah
um
it's just
you know i try to do
everything i can't uh when i think about
things
usually play video games or play guitar
keep my mind off of it
there used to be a german poker that
would go through all this time
and work out when that's going now
so i've had to figure out other things
today with
my depression
are you on medication for any of that
i'm not i refuse to take it because
to me it makes me worse
rather than better
oh really yeah
we tried it and i was getting worse and
worse and worse what kind of drugs are
you were you given
anti-depressants and sleep medication
but also when i was a child
i was on stuff like at all ripple and
stuff like that
i feel like that's affected my tape
but some of the stuff
like my decision making and stuff yeah
when you say decision making how does
how does that play out in your life
i'll always make the right decisions
really worse than most people
you know you have examples of how that's
happened in your life um
i just had that friend that was letting
hang around
she wouldn't
[Music]
wear money and never
give it back or she wouldn't
then she and i would get into it with
each other and then
it was just a mess
try not to think about it
[Music]
are you lonely
not really i have family around me
that's great yeah
what do you worry about now what are you
afraid of
um
i'm just worried when my parents go what
am i going to do with my wife you know
because they've always taken care of me
and
always have had the best interest for me
even though i don't say out loud with
them
one of tom
i always find that they're always right
[Music]
how do you feel about
you know this in this part of the
country this this part of appalachia
especially you
are surrounded by people
dealing with addiction
it's a very common story here it's
really scary
like i feel bad for the ones that are
addicted to stuff
i mean i know
maybe one or two people that i've ever
guessed and died
including
family members
i'm not going to mention their names or
anything
[Music]
because it just happened
um
my hobbies include playing guitar you
know
just do things like that help keep you
yeah
on track and not get depressed and yeah
that's great it's good to have something
like that
yeah
do you sometimes feel like life is
unfair that this happened to you
yeah sometimes but i go out keep in mind
too you know
things will always get better no matter
what how bad your situation is your
attitude seems pretty great yeah given
your circumstances yeah
i think most people
that would be in my circumstances worth
giving up by now
[Music]
and i've committed suicide or you know
dealt with it with drugs
audrey hadn't a suicide attempt once but
it was unsuccessful
which i'm really
blessed that didn't
you that would have been sad
yeah
do you do you feel like depre uh
uh betrayed by your your parents
my blood school family yeah because you
know
i never
was given a chance but
i've proved all the doctors and
everything else everyone else wrong
they said i wouldn't be able to walk or
talk
and yet
here i am yeah no you should be proud
yeah
that's why i would be on my own but i am
yeah you should be very proud of
yourself yeah
i mean your story is an inspiration to
i'm sure a lot of people that are going
through similar problems maybe not the
same exact one but yeah as many forms of
what you went through yeah
i mean
watch out
dark in some ways
but
there's times when i have dark humor
about it too
it's good to have a sense of humor yeah
i mean
i may not know my reason to be
on this earth but
you know
things will always
look up
even though
things are collapsing around you you
gotta look at it that way or you won't
survive
[Music]
does religion help you
yeah i'm actually a devoted christian
why do i go to church
very much but
i'm trying to get back into it
do you have goals in your life to do
anything
well or is it more just survival at this
point
survival because
i mean
i would love to have a family one day i
would love to
do a bunch of things travel you know
maybe
go to a few different concerts that have
bands that i like
have you been in love before awesome
have you been in love before
oh yeah several times
it's
not been easy in that area either i'm
sure yeah
i just
you know when i was when you're in high
school you think you know
the person that you fall in love with
there's going to be there forever
but you know
i'd lost contact with her several times
and then
when i finally got back there i found
out she was
married and was having kids
[Music]
that was really hard on me
i've asked few good relationships here
and there but
they never lasted
been
went off with this one girl for three
years
which
the united states
been pretty good to me
that's great yeah
and what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um well
there's so many of them
just be kind to others no matter what
your circumstances are because you don't
know
what they're going through
yeah that's a great one
yeah
all right robbie thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem i wish you
the best of luck thank you you should be
proud of yourself
yeah
okay
you